engineer you pitched as you mentioned
against bother on the 17th of august the
largest four hits and won that game as
the blue jays swept the three-game
series in baltimore hudson ray over's
last four starts has been outstanding
he is just really shut down the
opponents 10 hits over 22 innings in
four starts his record is two and oh
down the third baseline and there's
another oriole bunt base hit the bunting
his team in baseball has done it again
look at him go take what is given what a
great way to start you've got to put
pressure on this blue jays team
in on his hands and a fly ball hit to
left center field a long run grinching a
diving catch out in center field
they throw back to the infield is not in
time but what a sensational catch by
randall grichikon left center boy is he
playing well
defensively he rarely makes any mistakes
and right there he saved for you an
extra base hit for sure pat means was
scheduled to
pitch last night and they did not play
so he has been bumped up to this start
this will be his fifth start of the
season
and means has not faced the blue jace
this year
and he has faced him in the past of
course and
he is a lefty that has ticked up in his
velocity a bit this year he's gained
about two miles an hour on his fastball
popped up in a medium depth right field
and a play for santander the blue jays
make means throw 24 pitches but they go
three up three down
hit hard base hit into right field so
ron montcastle stays back and hits the
ball hard
and he's on with two down blue jays are
this aggressive and they even talking to
be more aggressive oh tomahawkda pitch
way up out of the zone for a base hit in
the center field that is classic hanzer
alberto just spoiling good pitches
vladimir guerrero jr leads off the
bottom of the fourth in a nothing
nothing game and swings
guerrero first pitch swinging deep right
field and gone
[Applause]
stay high
ten game history for vladimir guerrero
and he hits his fifth home run of the
season that's the first run of the ball
game now oscar hernandez swings at the
first pitch and he launches one
back-to-back home runs for the blue jays
well we mentioned john means has given
up some home runs home run
five and six that he has surrendered
this year and they come on back-to-back
pitches
fine drive center field base hit he's a
machine that's three of them
monster alberto just keeps delivering so
the bases are loaded now it's up to ryan
montcastle one for two ground ball
plumbed by shaw throws across and gets
away
a couple of runs in for the orioles
and this one's tied at 2-2
and it's the second time these two have
gone back-to-back this season and now
guerrero lashes the ball into left field
for a base hit it'll be cut off on the
track by mount castle vlady digging for
second and in there ahead of the throw
vladimir guerrero jr
can take a big lead at third as the ball
gets away and he'll coming to score
a wild pitch will give the blue jays the
lead
yes oh for two with a walk full count
pitch
oh yeah
he got that one into the night of
buffalo and we are tied boom goes renato
nunez
and it's 3-3
here's a high chopper can grechik beat
it out he sure can without a throw
and another chopper this one to short to
second one and no chance for a double
play so the top of the order enhancer
alberto
three hits on the night chance to give
the orioles a lead here
a little looper
and it might get down it's in for a base
hit and the orioles have the lead
poncer alberto it wasn't pretty but it's
his fourth hit of the game and the
orioles on top 4-3 and it got him to
chase a ball in the dirt
throw down to first to complete the out
and retire the side the orioles get one
we go to the bottom of the tent but it's
not over yet and randall grichik is up
one for four
and let's see what happens
and he sends a fly ball to center it is
d
is
[Applause]
and the blue jays find a way to win it
how about that
rando has just tied jose abreu for the
most home run since august 14th that's
his ninth home run that a big win for
the blue jays on a
tough night